hello everybody my name is Bruce Korf
I'm a medical geneticist in the
department of genetics at University of
Alabama at Birmingham it's great
pleasure to have an opportunity to
participate in this conference and I'll
be focusing for this next 45 minutes or
so on some of the educational challenges
that we face as genetics and genomics
are integrated into the day-to-day
practice of medicine these are my
disclosures neither of which is relevant
to any of the things that I'll be
talking about today I'm going to begin
with a quote that is more or less
familiar probably at least in general
terms I will read the whole thing but
fundamentally what it says is that
there's substantial concern about
whether healthcare professionals are
prepared to integrate genetics and I
would add genomics into day-to-day
clinical care most people who are
practicing medicine whether as
physicians nurses physician assistants
or any other context were trained
probably before the human genome
sequence was known and whatever they may
have learned about genetics and anything
they might have learned about genomics
if they remember it is already probably
out of date it's a moving target even
for individuals who are in the field to
keep up with so there has been concerned
that as the opportunities to integrate
genetics and genomics rapidly are
increasing that the degree of
preparedness of health professionals to
actually use this on a routine basis is
not keeping pace now with that being
said I'm going to begin and as you'll
see end as well on what I would deem to
be an optimistic note
which is that in spite of the fact that
I think it's true that clinicians are
largely unprepared in fact I think
things will work out and my evidence for
that isn't so much from the area of
genomics as much as it is from other
areas of Medicine and I think there are
plenty of previous experiences where new
technologies have been introduced that
at the time when they were introduced
clinicians also were unprepared but
somehow are managing to use those in a
very good example would be imaging
especially for example magnetic
resonance imaging part of my practice
involved seeing patients where imaging
is a very common thing to do and I order
MRI scans on my patients about
practically every day and I'm quite
comfortable knowing when to order the
test and knowing how to interpret the
results but if you were to ask me how
does mr i work in terms of the physics i
would be pretty much helpless to answer
that question i probably could give you
a very vague hand waving kind of
statement it would probably be largely
wrong but the truth is it doesn't really
affect my ability to know when to use
this and how to interpret the results
and I would take the position that very
much the same is going to be happening
in the area of genetics and genomics
there will need to be a cadre of
professionals who indeed do understand
the nuts-and-bolts in quite substantial
the tail but the majority of health
providers will need to have a working
knowledge and competency in using this
information but not necessarily a
details we have under the hood
familiarity so it's a point of return to
at the end but I think it's a really
important overall theme for this talk
let me give you a brief case history
actually that occurred in our clinic to
illustrate some of the challenges that
clinicians currently face so you're
looking at a family tree for a child the
arrow points to the 18 month old boy who
was seen by an endocrinologist actually
the presenting problem was chronic
diarrhea diarrhea that had been present
for a few weeks and didn't seem to be
getting better the reason an
endocrinologist was asked to see the
child is there is a family history the
darkened symbols represent individuals
who were phenotypically affected with
multiple endocrine neoplasia type 1 a
well-established clinical diagnosis in
this family and you can see the various
tumors that individuals with this
condition are at risk for and they
arguably include some that could
potentially present with chronic
diarrhea probably not very often at this
at this young age but nonetheless at
least it was a possibility well
recognizing that risk based on family
history a genetic test was sent by the
endocrinologist and this is a diagram
copy more or less from report what was
found was a so-called variant of
uncertain significance that somehow the
laboratory place smack between
pathogenic and benign so some variants
will have very clear pathogenic effects
that have a profound effect on the gene
and maybe have been reported before and
proven to be academic and others
represent the nine variants that are
just slight differences in base sequence
that have no phenotypic consequences oh
this one was kind of placed right
between those two and generally when a
variant of unknown significance is found
the conclusion is what the term implies
that we aren't sure what this means and
therefore it shouldn't be used as a
basis for clinical decision making
however
somehow it got interpreted in the
medical record as this child as a
mutation which indicates that he's
affected with the condition so that was
the conclusion that was reached
meanwhile the mother was seen by
different endocrinologist an adult
endocrinologist just based on her family
history who organized genetic testing
separately from the child through the
genetics clinic and she was found to
have a known pathogenic mutation that is
to say mutation that had been identified
and other patients with this condition
and was proven to have pathogenic
significance turned out that that
particular mutation was not present in
the child and the variant of unknown
significance that the child had was not
present in the mother and therefore must
have been inherited from the father so
it indicates this child in fact did not
inherit the mutation that was
responsible for multiple endocrine
neoplasia in the family their fourth
would not be affected with that
condition turns out as you probably are
aware to be very very difficult to erase
a diagnosis from the medical record let
me get to this day probably is still in
there in one way shape or form but it's
pretty clear that this child managed not
to inherit the pathogenic mutation in
the family and is not affected with
diarrhea on this basis it carried out by
the way the diarrhea resolved over time
and and then turned out to be a
gastroenteritis
so you can ask from the perspective of
the clinician who ordered protest what
kinds of competencies would be necessary
to provide care to this child with his
family history and how how did physician
fair from that perspective well you can
say the first thing is you need to know
that the family history does convey risk
that this child would inherit education
for men1 this could be fifty percent in
the physician clearly did recognize that
you can say that the child would need it
would need to be recognized at the child
might benefit from having a diagnosis
eighteen months is a bit early to screen
for men1 but it is something we do
screen for in childhood so generously
you could sort of put a check in fr and
you could say well if the child is at
risk of inheriting this and a diagnosis
needs to be made that m en genetic
testing is available and clearly that
was recognised too then when the result
comes back appreciate the significance
of this variant of unknown significance
and well that clearly was not
demonstrated because this was
interpreted by the clinician as a
mutation which would indicate the
diagnosis which was not in case might
hope that a clinician would recognize
that you would want to test an affected
relative like the mother first and
establish what actually the pathogenic
mutation is and that clearly wasn't done
you formulate an appropriate care plan
well that's a debatable point child
obviously nenda doesn't have this
condition and probably this wouldn't
have accounted for symptoms at that
young age anyway so you can ask the
broad question indeed what are the
necessary set of knowledge and skills
required both to analyze interpret and
then to utilize utilize genomic
information in day-to-day medical
practice
now would argue that one needs to focus
first of all on competencies not
knowledge so the question is and what do
I think that clinicians should know it's
what do I think they should be able to
do since that really is the ultimate
test or whether they're going to be able
to use this information or not and I
think one of the mistakes we often make
in genetics actually in teaching is to
go into the huge depth about the nuts
and bolts of genomics which is great fun
and really interesting for those of us
that do it but they not be appreciated
entirely by students who are not going
to be doing it but may indeed be using
it and so I think you need to be very
clear on what we do and don't expect
clinicians to be able to do I'll return
to this point later but we'll make it
now that a broad of what's going to
happen on believe is the development of
point of care decision support tools
that will guide clinicians in their use
of how much physicians need to be able
to know how to do versus to be guided to
do at the right moment remains a
question but I would not want to leave
the impression that we are hoping to
train a generation who are going to just
know which key depressed on the computer
when told to do so and if you have any
illusions that we don't think it's
important for clinicians to at least
have some understanding of the rationale
for what they do let the stern visit
Abraham Flexner set you straight that a
health provider need should be able to
explain why they're doing what they're
doing not only what in hell so what I
want to do in the next few minutes is to
analyze genetics and genomics as it
relates to medical practice from three
perspectives these are diagnosis
prevention and therapy which I think are
the three main arenas in which genomics
is important so you see here odot very
small blood smear
an individual with sickle-cell anemia
and this is well in some ways you could
argue this was the first genetic test
and it's a test that is from a technical
perspective very straightforward to do
and the reason why is that one hundred
percent of people with sickle cell
anemia have the same exact single base
pair of substitution mutation so
performing and interpreting that test
really is straightforward it doesn't
mean providing care is straightforward
but if the issue is genetic testing it's
either that the mutation is either
present or not present in a homozygous
form for an affected person or
heterozygous form for a carrier that's
pretty much all there is to it contrast
that with cystic fibrosis a relatively
common autosomal recessive condition
where they're probably at this point
thousands of different mutations that
have been found however just a couple of
dozen mutations roughly account for
ninety-nine percent or so of individuals
who are affected actually one particular
mutation itself account for about
two-thirds of the all mutations in this
gene so the testing is fairly
straightforward in most cases but there
are examples where one has to look a lot
harder for a mutation and where there
could be variants of unknown
significance that occasionally be found
so the testing is again fairly
straightforward but not only so then
next on the spectrum is disorder which
is really the focus of my personal
interest in research neurofibromatosis
type 1 and conditions associated with
tumors along the course of peripheral
nerves the diagram to the upper left
shows an example of the map of the gene
with each of the markings below it or
above it represent different asians our
lab here at UAB which does testing we
found something over 3,000 distinct
mutations in this gene
in the course of the decade or so that
we've been doing testing we still just
that every week find it previously
undescribed mutation that we can prove
is pathogenic and so it's a very
complicated test and lots of things
happen that are unexpected mutations are
found that look like they could be
pathogenic but aren't or that look like
they shouldn't be pathogenic but are you
need a lot of sophistication to
interpret that test accurately in recent
years genomic testing has become
mainstream in the context of chromosomal
analysis I'll be familiar with
cytogenetic studies that detect extra or
missing chromosomal material probably
the most famous of these and best-known
is doing a karyotype looking to see if
there's an extra copy of chromosome 21
down syndrome is suspected it's very
straightforward tests to do and it's
been possible to do for more than 50
years now but in the past few years this
has moved largely from a cytological
test to and molecular test through the
advent of sight of genomic micro arrays
and this has made a very significant
improvement in our pickup rate in
conditions such as autism spectrum
disorder and intellectual disability
where we move for maybe a five percent
detection rate too close to a 20-percent
detection rate there's not a hundred
percent so there's plenty that we missed
but nonetheless a very substantial
improvement over the historical rate of
detection and then in these past maybe
three or so years finally the ability to
actually sequence genomes to be able to
do either an exome or genome sequence to
try to identify a mutation in an
individual who is affected with some
phenotype which has the potential of
sort of breaking this cycle that
illustrate here in the so-called
diagnostic Odyssey where you
try to make a differential diagnosis
order appropriate genetic tests try to
interpret them and if that's not the
right mutation you keep going around in
circles each time spending a lot of
money causing a lot of frustration not
necessarily answering the question an
exome sequencing now is done on a
routine basis actually to try to
identify mutations where either a priori
we don't have any idea of what the
mutation might be or there are too many
candidate games to test at once and it
becomes more cost-effective to sequence
the 20,000 plus genes comprising the
exone all the express sequences rather
than test one gene at a time so big
questions in terms of what dude
clinicians need to be able to do to
interpret this and I would make the
point that especially as we get into
exome sequencing approaches things get
complicated very quickly this is a
screenshot from the paper published in
science translational medicine a couple
of years ago showing that virtually
everybody is a carrier for at least one
and sometimes multiple different
recessive conditions and even on top of
that that many of the variants that they
found in this particular study were
annotated in the literature as being
Catholic genic but in fact were not
necessarily accurately determined to be
pathogenic so some of the so-called
pathogenic mutations have turned out to
be in fact nonpathogenic variants of
unknown significance and the literature
is not always reliable in this point
there are examples where mutations got
reported sometimes decades ago and then
kind of forgotten about and as evidence
further accumulated it became clear they
weren't pathogenic but people didn't
always go back and update for literature
so becomes a big issue in terms of
accurately
interpreting needs of not taking a
communication record at face value
there's also the potential of incidental
findings I showed this painting to use
the metaphor if you saw somebody walking
down the street with a flower pot about
to fall on their head would you call
attention to that and the equivalent in
exome sequencing is the possibility of
incidental findings looking for one
thing by the cause of a let's say a
child with intellectual disabilities and
discovering something totally unexpected
like a risk of breast and ovarian cancer
give you a BRCA mutation well the
American College of medical genetics and
genomics issued a statement about this
in 2013 and updated just this past few
months recommending that 56 genes be
scrutinized for mutations that would
have major medical significance all of
these are actual genes that if you take
ins found convey a high risk of a
condition where there's a better medical
outcome from early diagnosis and the
argument here is that you may not have
been working for that cancer related
mutation once you have found it there's
a responsibility to report it now there
is a an opt-out option for patients wear
whatever reason after pretest counseling
they've decided they don't want to
notice so far examine because I
understand it from the community and I
can tell you to be true with my own
patients a very few choose to opt out
given the potential even of life-saving
information about conditions that
predisposed to cancer or to cardiac
arrhythmia but anyway the opt out is at
least offered as a possibility but again
this requires a lot of sophistication on
the part of the clinician to be able to
explain this kind of thing to a patient
about undergo testing
in the danger is that as you look at the
genome sequence and you think back to
well what did you learn about genetics
or genomics in well high school college
medical school nursing school or
whatever your postgraduate education was
if there's one thing you remember is
probably that the genetic code is a
three-letter code we letters encode any
particular amino acid and it's easy to
get lulled into asking yourself well
just how hard could that be if it's just
a three-letter code and some people use
the metaphor of the genome is the book
of life and if you were to stick with
that metaphor and say so what is an
example of a book that uses three letter
words this may come to mind and notice
is it as simple as reading a dr. Seuss
book to interpret the genetic code so my
argument would be that no it isn't that
if you do want to use a literary
metaphor in genomics this is a better
book to be thinking about any of you who
have tried to read or have read ulysses
realize that you could teach a
first-grader we've just learned to read
to read Ulysses if you mean by that
pronounce the words that are written on
the paper that the chances that
individual would be able to understand
the nuances read between the lines know
the obscure references that are embedded
in this text pretty slim hard enough for
adults to do that and reading the genome
sequence that you could read the amino
acids for a game easily enough but
looking at the nuances reading between
the lines knowing what's pathogenic or
not is a much much more complicated
undertaking if you want to stretch a
literary metaphor one more step it is
not difficult to reach a point where you
pass through the looking glass and
things you thought you knew don't turn
out to be true mutations that look
pathogenic aren't epigenetic changes
occur so there's a lot of nuance here
that requires in turn a lot of
sophistication
what about any area of prevention well
geneticists have been involved in
population scale prevention since the
1960s with the advent of newborn
screening in the theory here was that if
you could make a diagnosis before the
onset of symptoms based on
identification of a analyte and blood
which indicates a condition like PKU
phenylketonuria due to the inability to
break down phenylalanine that you could
Institute treatment that takes the form
of dietary manipulation and avoid a
devastating outcome and if you wait for
symptoms to occur it's too late so the
idea was to test right in the newborn
period and then Institute treatment
promptly if the Admiral screen occurs
and then to confirm the diagnosis but
shut at the bottom is the diagram of
tandem mass spectrometry the original
test which is illustrated at the very
top was a bacterial inhibition assay but
now what is injected into a ten domestic
drama terr and a reading it's then done
that can look potentially for dozens of
abnormal analytes vastly expanding the
scope of newborn screening however you
know if you're in the shoes of the
pediatrician who gets a call Friday at
four thirty in the state lab that says
there was an abnormal screen what do you
do the chances are most pediatricians it
will be a pediatrician who sneezing
newborns most pediatricians if they
learned about some of the metabolic
disorders have had very limited
experience with them and it may have
been years since they took care of a
child with some of the more obscure
conditions so how would one expect them
to know what to do in that late
afternoon call American College of
medical genetics and genomics is put
together a set of so called act sheets
which are an example is shown on this
slide that consists of a very brief kind
of step-by-step here are the immediate
things to do
to provide appropriate care for that
child and it's assumed that for some of
these obscure disorders it's going to be
necessary to engage the assistance of an
expert metabolic disease but here are
the things to think about before you get
that person on the phone to deal with
the most immediate and emergent kinds of
issues and you can see there's also a
kind of flow chart provided and I think
this kind of model will apply to many
areas of genetics and genomics we don't
necessarily assume that all health
providers will be able to carry all the
interpretation managed conditions on
their own shoulders you would expect
that they will rely on colleagues for
assistance and backup but to put a very
succinctly at their disposal to at least
help them to know what's the next step
and what are the things going forward
that they need to be launching for well
there's been a lot of interest in risk
assessment based on genomics especially
who the results of genome-wide
Association studies and it spawned a set
of companies that have been offering
direct-to-consumer testing the ideas you
basically give them the credit card
number send the samples oftens sample of
spit they analyze it for mostly about a
million single nucleotide polymorphisms
and then provide a web-based
interpretation not all of these
companies still are in this field it was
in a little bit of natural selection
here and one major one left standing is
temporarily at least or currently
involved in a debate with the FDA to get
approval to actually include some of the
medical interpretations so it's
generated a lot of anxiety in the
medical community because patients can
access this testing without the
intervention of the clinician Google's
all on their own inequality at least it
might be with a lot of the data reported
back in terms of educational is quite
good however the quality of the risk
assessments may be a very different
better based on very limited data sets
and there's been concerned about whether
patients might in accurately interpret
some of what they get back from this
neither thinking they're at higher or
potentially a roller vez than they
really are also realizing that the
genomic contribution to risk for many of
the common conditions like type 2
diabetes or hypertension may be modest
and so you may be chipping away at the
edges of this so anyway it's generated a
lot of concern it would make the
argument that this may be an example of
a so-called disruptive technology this
is a diagram I've modified from a book
by clay Christensen has formulated this
idea disruptive technology is one that
when it's introduced is nowhere close to
the power of whatever the mainstream
technology is a good example is the
introduction of personal computers in
the late 1970s at a time when computers
filled a room and you couldn't run a
business off a personal computer back in
those days you could play games on them
which is probably what a lot of people
did and so they were dismissed at first
but over time the quality gets better
and better as indicated by the green
line and what starts off as kind of a
toy he borrows into a very serious tool
in case of the personal computer some of
the companies that were arguing
mainframe computers are no longer in
business got swallowed up by some little
person computer tokens as applied to
risk assessment in genetics the current
paradigm of a physician or genetic
counselor working one-on-one with the
patient one being at a time shown by the
red line may get better and better in a
implement away but it is possible and of
course I can't know that this is true
that the consumer driven testing which
may be kind of recreational more than
medical right now as the datasets get
better may eventually surpass the one
game at a time
cochin one thing is for sure and that is
if we're going to be doing genome scale
testing the one game at a time approach
to counseling is just not going to be
sustainable so we are going to need to
be looking somewhere renewed counseling
models whether this particular one is
the right one yes is a point that many
will want to debate what about in the
area of therapeutics so one of the
poster cases for genome informed
therapeutics is in that nip which was
developed based on knowledge of the BCR
Abel translocation that occurs in
chronic myelogenous leukemia that
creates a fusion gene and a novel
peptide it was possible to develop this
drug that blocks an ATP binding site and
effectively turns off that pathway and
has made a big difference in the
treatment of chronic myelogenous
leukemia and some other forms of cancer
as well this notion of targeting
therapies based on understanding of
molecular mechanisms certainly has been
a major area of interest although you
could make the argument that actually
use a magnum as opposed to developing
imagine was it really necessary to know
genetics you had to know a lot of
genetics to develop it you don't need to
know it on a moment to moment basis to
use it so much here's I realized small
are some examples of mutation tests
either for her to New amplification and
breast cancer for a graph mutation that
occurs in melanoma and can be used as a
basis for deciding which particular
treatment is likely to be most effective
for a particular cancer the diagram of
the right shows the ability to do cancer
genome analysis which is being done on a
increasingly wide basis to try to get to
the bottom of particular cancers what
the various catalog of genetic King is
is that drives that cancer in Qatar
therapy according to the specific
fingerprint or profile of the tumor so
another area where genomics is really
moved to center stage then
pharmacogenetics where this is the
pathway for activity and excretion of
warfarin commonly used blood thinner
where two polymorphisms one involved in
its target the course of one and one
involved in its excretion are both
subject to genetic modification by
particular common mutations in
population and using these as a basis
for deciding the exact dosage of work
wind is pretty well established to speed
up the achievement of a therapeutic
dosage that is not give too much which
causes a risk of hemorrhage nor too
little which causes a risk of blood
cotton what's debated is not whether
this is clinically valid or whether it's
clinically useful can you get the
testing in a timely basis and there's a
cost effective here I would argue that
how much physicians and others who
prescribe medications need to know
except in general terms about
pharmacogenetics is limited I don't
think musicians are going to be sitting
there with a calculator recalculating
work when dosage each time a patient
goes on treatment but one can argue is
this is demonstrated to be clinically
useful but the electronic prescribing
systems should integrate the results of
this testing into the prescribing
information and so when you get a pretty
patient on medication it should flag
well this is somebody you need to adjust
those from whatever the standard
starting those things to something else
because they're at risk of hemorrhage
for example but with all of this now
having made some comments about
diagnosis population and screening and
prevention and therapy how do we
approach some of the educational
challenges first from the professional
genetic
point of view personal you should know
that there is such a thing as a
professional geneticist does generally a
two-year residency in genetics typically
following some kind of residency in a
acgme accredited program in areas like
Pediatrics or adult medicine for example
but now on three occasions the genetics
community has held meetings of the
Banbury conference center near Cold
Spring Harbor the first in 2004 to talk
about how to increase numbers of
trainings at that time the big issue was
getting more people with adult training
into genetics the second occurring in
2006 focused on what exactly is a
medical geneticist and what is the scope
of practice and Keira Keira and a third
that occurred just a few months ago
looked at genetics training in the
genomic era how do we keep clinicians up
to speed when they trained in an era
where nobody with sequencing the genomes
but they are now if I were to summarize
a lot of this into one slide it's the
notion of establishing a kind of vector
of competency we need to do a better job
of marketing genetics and genomics and
making sure that students are aware that
there are career opportunities there and
being sure that students who matriculate
into medical school at least have some
basic familiarity with genetics and
genomics that needs to be integrated
into medical education and residency and
over time into their CMA and especially
maintenance of certification activities
which provides a great opportunity to
reach individuals who are currently out
in practice indeed the importance of
genetics and genomics and medical
education was highlighted a few years
ago and by a stettler really a project
undertaken by Howard Hughes Medical
Institute and the association of
american medical colleges susan
committee that I served on and they were
concerned about the basic science
background that undergraduates were
getting before they matriculated in
medical school and then subsequently the
training that they actually got in
medical school this is the competency
that was identified for genetics
everybody came to this meeting with
laundry list of things they thought
students should be able to do know and
everybody was equally disappointed that
their discipline got only a few lines or
paragraphs that I guess it was if you
measure success by everybody's equal and
unhappy it achieved that but in fact I
think it maintained a very good focus on
what's really important and in this case
this covers a lot of territory this is
the competency in genetics now i'll say
this slightly predated some of the
genomic testing now being done so in
that sense it may be out of date but
they also asked the question you know
where for example medical school
admission very commonly requires
knowledge or things like organic
chemistry and calculus might it be more
important to include genetics on
prerequisites and how often do you
actually use calculus in day-to-day
medical practice as opposed to genetic
so there have been some suggested
changes in both pre medical and medical
curricula as a result of this well
recently the National Human Genome
Research Institute has been funding a
group called the intersociety
Coordinating Committee on smc a theory
there was that a lot of the postgraduate
training is under the aegis of
professional societies and they thought
by bringing the professional societies
together they might be able to get
synergy in terms of including genetics
and genomics in the curriculum both for
residents and training and maintenance
of certification
so I chaired a working group on
competencies in that process and we
identified six areas called observable
professional activities the trustable
professional activities rather epa's
that basically say what do you expect a
clinician in this case a position to be
able to do like to elicit document and
act on relevant family history or
utilized genomic testing to guide
patient management so there were six of
those each of them then was defined in
terms of a set of competencies that were
written according to the ACG and the six
competencies model of it probably
familiar with and I won't go into detail
about these except to refer you to the
paper on this in genetics and medicine
we didn't expect that a
one-size-fits-all approach would work so
there was no expectation that the exact
competencies put forth in that document
would without modification be used for
probably for any clinician whether a
generalist or a specialist but we
thought this could provide a starting
point so if a cardiology group wanted to
formulate the competencies delivered to
a cardiologist that this would be a
jumping off point to do that the same
for the proj of an oncologist or a
gastroenterologist any case these have
been published now and refer you to the
article to get more detail about those
the genetics community has done the same
met about three years ago to formulate
competencies in medical genetics I want
to show you all these they were public
in genetics and medicine and can be
found on the ACMG net web site these are
of course focused not on the generalist
commission but on the medical geneticist
profession where obviously a much higher
level of competency is expected
how do we get more people to recognize
the opportunities for genetics training
and to go into the field well one of the
more successful I think approaches
successful at least in terms of buying I
can't yet say whether it's successful in
terms of increasing the number of excuse
me of cranes has been the American
College of medical genetics and genomics
foundation Summer Scholars program where
students can apply in their first year
of medical school to spend the summer
viewing a kinetic genomic project and
observing usually in clinic learn
laboratory settings and now several
dozen students over the past yes this is
the fourth year it's been done have
taken place taking part rather in this
and have had a first-hand exposure now
you know whether this will entice some
to actually stay in the field and seek
training or provide more sensitivity
about the issues in genetics and
genomics remains to be seen but I think
it's been a good program in terms of
getting least a buzz in the medical
school class about the opportunities
here and for sure there are a new
educational paradigm that we could be
using and probably should be using so
here the possibility of so-called
massive open online courses the Khan
Academy sort of microbe courses this is
an interesting model that might be
applied this is an iBook that we put
together for a course it's really more
research than clinically oriented here
at UAB um where you can deliver a
lecture content too many materials
quizzes and so forth into that kind of a
format for things like iTunes University
other similar kinds of approaches for
distance learning so all of these things
are available to begin to experiment
with paradigms that are above and beyond
the
traditional lecture approach that most
clinicians are most familiar with so I'm
going to end on a few speculations about
the future the first is you often hear
it said that a day will come when
everybody will have their genome
sequenced and question I'll ask is if
cell when would you do it in the course
of a person's lifetime not when we'd be
doing it on a wide scale when in a
person's life would you do it the second
where would the information live so you
can actually sequence pedo genome from a
blood sample taken from the leather
we're very small amounts of fetal DNA
kind of reaches into the mother's blood
doesn't last very long there but any one
time it will be some and you can
actually use that as a source of DNA
sequence in principle you can sequence
the fetal genome even before birth and
whether it's a good idea to do that's a
different matter the same could be
applied to newborn screening where the
National Human Genome Research Institute
now is finding set of studies looking at
the efficacy of newborn screening by
genetic diagnosis the advantage neither
of these is you get a very early
diagnosis that means if it was an
intervention can be applied reasonable
coughlin on the other hand will be a lot
of issues to lemon you can obtain proper
informed consent accountants in Atlanta
newborn we seem to deal with that and
things like newborn screening will we
for genomic sequencing I guess is the
question you can also displayed a little
while and do it in childhood but some of
the same issues in terms of consent and
what do you do if you're discovering
adult onset disorder or rice or you can
wait till adulthood when you can give
consent but maybe it's too late to
intervene in some ways that might have
an artificial so their arguments on both
sides there and then if you did it you
could ask so we're with the data live so
one possibility is in the electronic
health record
see don't think possibility too many
because of the storage requirements that
it entails and it is limited by the fact
that it's pretty hard to get medical
records sent from one hospital to
another in the conventional form imagine
trying to do it for genomic information
and very few people live their lives
affiliated with just a single medical
center those times these days somebody
might be born in one hospital give care
as a child and another and develop as
another and also people need round and
what happens if you're traveling the day
something happens that your genome
sequence couldn't be useful for will you
have access to it you can and some do
put their genome sequence on personal
devices it is possible to do that you
still have to remember to bring it with
you doc break it or lose it but it is
there potentially powerful approach and
finally my favorite is the cell nucleus
seems to being delivered so far anyway
the most efficient place ever devised to
and storage genomic information and it
may evolve to a point where it will be
cheaper to re-sequence genome every time
you want to use it rather than bother
storing the information you can
conclusions so it's possible that
sequencing will come down and up in
price that it will be essentially free
and cheaper to be again them to pod
restoring all the genomic information
hard to know in this is been and will
continue to be a moving target take them
on degree for some time you could ask
the question with all of this winter
clinicians really likely to be using
this under routine basis and the
screenshot I'm showing you is from
iTunes not from a medical source and
that really is fundament and
fundamentally my argument that
clinicians will use this routinely the
day somebody comes up with a medical
record system is powerful and intuitive
and easy and fun to use as iTunes you
think back
gene or some years people were getting
music downloaded onto mp3 players often
illegally Kristen just was no practical
way to do it you're so convenient and I
don't think if necessarily minded paying
a small amount per song they download it
just needed a way to do with them
efficient to ative and funny that's what
this was and there others in that
landscape now but the point is that's
the kind of breakthrough that was
required I think very much the same
stream of electronic medical records
most clinicians I know finding the good
frustrating much of the time because
design captured this kind of information
the day somebody integrates genomic
information same clarity and simplicity
in spite of the complexities which are
behind the scenes there's itunes that's
the day when I think seeing much more
widespread use so what needs to happen I
guess I'll make for final points one
word a long way from having a fully
annotated genomes and they'll be in a
while I'm sure so we'll eat lots of
variants of unknown significance but
that shouldn't discourage produced it
just means that you've got to partner
with a really sophisticated geneticist
and lab or even in the clinic to
accurately interpret what's found the
second I think we're going to see more
and more use of point of care decision
support tools such as i mentioned
pharmacogenetics collaboration and
partnerships among specialties will be
absolutely necessary and new counseling
paradigms what is the director similar
one takes off or others we aren't going
to be able to sustain counseling one
team at a time when we're testing one
genome at it one so with that I'll end
with a quote that I find now is being
used more and more so maybe it's a
little trite but I think it applies
really well here the best way to predict
the future is to Bennett I don't know
exactly when or how
a lot of these things will unfold but
what makes this such an exciting time in
genetics especially and in medicine in
general is this opportunity to write the
book on how genetics and genomics will
be integrated into medical practice so
with that I'm going to wrap up I know
that there are some questions and I'll
now open the site and begin to take a
look at those
cy sure heralds I sit here so the first
question says developing medicines and
treatments specific to individual
genetic makeups to improve effectiveness
is one thing it is also possible to use
genetic makeup to cover population of
the imperfections and defects in this
result in a more perfect society with
the desired genetic makeup thoughts on
the possibility and how to prevent it
Society does so well I guess my answer
there is that you know the sort of
eugenic possibilities and what many
would view is the kind of misuse of
genomics to select for traits that
somebody decides might be desirable
honestly I think we're a very very long
way from that I actually am a bit of a
skeptic I didn't quite say this way but
I am about our ability even to predict
major common disorders type 2 diabetes
for example people have been trying to
get at that for quite some while and I
my concern is that in genomic sort of
make up that predicts that may be so
complicated and individual is to defy
even that being able to be done so you
know the kind of things people will talk
about like athletic performance and
intelligence and other kind of common
traits hair color eye color whatever
like they're multifactorial they involve
the simultaneous effects of multiple
genes I frankly think it's really going
to be difficult to select those to a
degree that will really sort of achieve
the kind of eugenic sort of fears that
many people have so I tend to worry
about it less than how it's sometimes
described another question humanism it'd
perfect entity subject and water
imperfections from environmental
influences can this technology be used
to create the perfect team well I think
we've just answered that the answer is
no I'm not even sure what would define
the perfect unity so we're on an
individual finds that they're
predisposed to pancreatic cancer how has
it helped them aside from being
depressed so you know I want to try to
tackle a particular individual condition
in a public talk of this kind but I will
say that the paradigm of genetic testing
for cancer risk is increasingly well
established the one where it's probably
best established we're the ones would be
breast ovarian and colon cancer where
it's really clear that if you find your
genetic risk there are interventions now
you know one of them will be mastectomy
or surveillance this would apply to
colon cancer as well and there's
absolutely no doubt that you can improve
outcomes with this knowledge it becomes
a lot tougher with some cancers
pancreatic cancer actually ovarian
cancer arguably is in this category to
what make both of them so difficult is
that they cancers can kind of hide in
tissues deep inside the body until they
get pretty far advanced and then can be
hard to treat there are surveillance
approaches that exist including for
pancreatic cancer and you know I guess
one usually gets testing done because of
family history and in that case there's
already concerned and you know I'm sure
it is a tough thing for people to deal
with that on one hand but increasingly
there are interventions that allow early
diagnosis and promised better outcomes
especially for things like breast
ovarian colon cancer but I think we had
a cancer is subject to surveillance
next question with the affordable health
care law in effect could we see a future
there being a requirement that everybody
needs to submit to genomic
identification and maybe it would
increased efficacy for treatment and
medications more selective so now I do
think what you're going to find I don't
think we're at a point and we're close
to a point where everybody's gonna be
required to have their genome sequence
available whether we'll ever reach a
point where that will become routine but
you know I kind of thing least a little
bit of discussion of that however I
think one thing you will see and
actually already do see in some cases is
that if there is let's say a very
expensive and probably toxic
chemotherapy being opposed to use and
there's a genetic test that will predict
what you will or will respond to it you
could argue that it would be
irresponsible to put somebody on a
medication if you could predict in
advance that they won't respond to it
especially if it's a toxic one or a very
expensive one and there already are
instances where drugs will only be used
if a genetic test indicates that you're
the kind of person who will respond I
don't see that as discriminatory I see
that is just logical Newsome technology
because it would be kind of wasteful and
foolhardy even to use a medication
that's guaranteed to fail if you could
figure that out in advance and then
select one that has a better chance of
working in the last question i see this
says there is a need for population in
general education that's a good point
I've been focusing on professional
education but there's a lot of need for
public education here as well part of
partly to dispel some of the myths so
which we've been talking about in the
last few minutes partly so people can
make better-informed decisions for their
health care based on what I predict will
be the increased use of genetics and
genomics in day-to-day medical practice
so this needs to be integrated into
general education as well as
professional
so that appears to be the last question
so at this point thank you very much for
your attention and hope that this was
helpful thank you